What have we learned about the behavior of exponential functions so far? Well,
once again, working with our general function, f of x equals a to the x. If a
is greater than 1, then f of x is increasing everywhere in this domain, showing
exponential growth. If 0 is less than a is less than 1, then the function looks
like this one. It's decreasing everywhere in its domain, and we say that it
shows exponential decay. There is, however, another way that functions of this
type are sometimes written out. I've graphed four different functions over
here, and I'd like you to tell me which one is equivalent to the function we
were talking about before? f of x equals 1 3rd to the x. I'd like you to think
about this, using both equations I've written here and the graphs that are
drawn.